what's going on people in this video
i'll be breaking down a couple things
you might have missed in the teaser
trailer for my hero academia season six
and also be giving my reaction to the
news that the my hero manga is ending in
2022. at jump festa earlier today
hirokoshi officially confirmed that his
plan is to end the manga next year which
is obviously massive news however he did
leave open the small possibility that
things might continue a tiny bit longer
later in the video i'll be giving my
thoughts on what he said but first let's
break down the season 6 teaser trailer
ok so one of the first shots from this
trailer was this image of the paranormal
liberation front which is a new villain
organization led by shigaraki an
interesting thing to notice is that riy
destro is now using a walking stick
after his fight in the last season as
during his battle with shiguraki he was
forced to cut off his own feet to stop
his whole body from decaying since then
he's had prosthetic feet implanted
allowing him to walk when he's not using
his high-tech wheelchair
in the background we also have giganto
machia who is now wearing two arm
gauntlets which are more clearly visible
in the manga panel of this same moment
and of course in the center we have
shiguraki in his brand new style
as the successor to all for one him
wearing his suit is just a subtle way of
showing that he's ascended to that role
and just like afo his hair is now white
something that happened in the anime
last season after his awakening
moving on the teaser then goes on to
show us several glimpses of the heroes
getting ready for war with the villains
and without giving away spoilers it's
clear that the heroes have been split
into different locations
for example we have endeavor and his
group who were inside a building whereas
midoriya and his group are outside as
their job is to evacuate the civilians
from the city there's also a third team
of heroes who are somewhere else and on
the front lines you can see there's a
small group of students in particular
denki mudman mushroom girl and tamaki
amajiki in the back of this shot there's
a character with a handsaw for a head
and this is something that they've
changed from the manga because in
chapter 259 this same guy was actually
chainsaw man as in the real chainsaw man
from the manga of the same name this was
just a casual easter egg that harakoshi
included but for whatever reason he's
now hand saw man in the anime which i
imagine is a lot less effective
as a side note i read the chainsaw man
manga last year and i'd recommend it
because it was unlike anything i'd read
before especially towards the end it was
getting like really chaotic
and at the very least herikoji seems to
be a fan as well
anyway as the season 6 teaser continued
we got a brief look at the evil doctor
ujuko and all for one before the teaser
then ended on this shot of shigeraki
recovering inside a tank the last time
we saw this character he was being torn
apart by the doctor as part of an
experiment to enhance his body and
enhance his quirk ujko said that the
overall procedure would take four months
to complete and once that time was up
shigaraki would have the power to take
one for all
a large aspect of season six is the
heroes trying to prevent this fully
powered shigiraki from being completed
hence why this was likely the best shot
they could have ended the trailer on
without spoiling anything in the process
now in terms of hirokoshi's letter that
was read out of jamfester he revealed
that if things go to plan the my
academia manga will be complete within
one year while this is big news it's not
entirely surprising considering that
only seven months ago we got a chapter
titled the final act begins
from that moment we should have been
bracing ourselves for an announcement
like this as hirokoshi seems to now have
a solid idea of how the series will be
ending he went on to say that bakugou
will have a huge role in the finale and
that he hopes that those who love and
hate bakugou will enjoy it on top of
that toga and ochako will have a final
confrontation and understandably
shiguraki will be deku's biggest
obstacle as it's still unclear whether
or not midoriya will be able to save him
my honest thoughts on this series ending
next year is that based on where the
story is right now it makes sense but i
am slightly disappointed that the things
we'll likely never get to see for
example things like an internship in the
usa or a second sports festival or even
exploring the kids second and third
years at ua there's not really any time
to do that anymore because you know it'd
just be it would have to be squeezing at
the end and it just wouldn't be fleshed
out i guess what i'm trying to say is
that if my hero ends next year and we
never get a sequel series then i
personally feel like there's a lot of
things about this whole world that were
left unexplored however you gotta
respect the fact that hirokoshi is just
telling the story he wants to tell and
isn't milking it just for the sake of it
there's also the possibility that
there's a spin-off manga like my hero
academia vigilantes i mean that could
still be a thing after the main series
is done because hirokoshi himself
wouldn't necessarily have to do it we
also know that the studio loves to make
new movies i mean that will likely
continue long after the manga is done i
remember there was a rumor a long time
ago that they were meant to be like nine
or ten movies i think uh i don't know if
that was true but i mean we've been
getting movies every year so
possible that when the manga is complete
we'll still be getting movies for years
and years and years as long as the anime
keeps going at least
anyway guys let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below both about the
trailer and about my academia ending and
don't forget to smash that sub button to
stay up to date with videos like this
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out